dire là maintenant alors ah bah là je
vais me mettre à côté bah très bien avec
plaisir alors on va passer un invité du
S on va revenir sur cette fameuse
émission diffusée hier soir sur France 2
complément d'enquête toujours bien sûr
complément d' toujours une émission à
l'objectivité bien sûr qui qui fait
parler dans dans dans dans tout le PAF
et en France entière l'émission
s'intéresse à Jordan bardellaa le
président du Rassemblement national
bizarrement déjà complément d'enquête
ils ont vu ils s'intéressent surtout aux
gens qui sont susceptibles de leur faire
de l'audience euh c'est vrai aujourd'hui
c'est une course à l'audence pour
complément d'enquête ils ont fait
gérardo pardieu ils ont fait Jordan
mardella ils ont fait Philippe devider
j'ai ils ont fait mon mon portrait
également et c'est vrai que en audience
on peut pas dire le contraire ça marche
bien regardez puisque regardez ça marche
plus que les déchets nucléaires derrière
voilà ça marche c'est vrai regardez
avant regardez regardez les sujets avant
c'est vrai que c'est ça qui est drôle
déchets nucléaires meurtre espion et
violence conjugale police c'était un bon
sujet ça c'est un sujet important 741000
et PPDA
100ion7 gerérardo par 1ion Jordan
Bardella 1 et c'est vrai qu'on a fait 3
millions c'est même moi quand je le vois
3 millions on a fait quand même
complment nucléire 500000 à Nouna 3
million déchet nucléire en plus c'est un
peu le même sujet c'est deuxah c'est
deux sujets sur des sur des déchets
Jordan Mella a fait une petite vanne sur
TikTok avant la diffusion de l'émission
regardez et il nous rejoint vous allez
voir il arrive là c'est
parti il a tout dans le P mais ce n'est
pas un Le Pen
complémentqute l'ANT prodige R qui sera
grand remplaçant de Marine Le Pen voire
d'Emmanuel Macron je Jordane mardella
est avec nous président du Rassemblement
national est-ce que déjà vous êtes
content d'avoir eu votre complément
d'enquête c'est un peu une
consécration quand vous faites de la
politique vous êtes sur un escalier et
puis plus vous montez plus on essaie de
vous pousser sur le côté exactement donc
je je m'y attendais ça fait un an de
qu'on attend la diffusion de ce
reportage qui a été décalé à trois
reprises qui trouvait pas grandchose et
donc un an de track sur ma vie privée ma
vie
personnelle sur ma famille sur les gens
qui ont partagé ma vie euh on est allé
voir sur mes mes mes jobs étudiants que
j'ai fait quand j'étais étudiant si
j'avais bien travaillé enfin j'ai eu la
totale quoi au moins vous savez que je
suis clean on va revenir sur tous les ex
sa c'est comme moi le ce complément
d'enquête m'a fait du bien je suis je
suis lavé ça fait du bien mais je vous
jure que c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
en fait quand il passe comme ça on se
dit tranquille vousê lasérisé ou ah
ouais j'adore vous fait un beau score 1
million et demi c'est pas mal oui on n a
pas fait trop de publicité trop de
publicité avant ça fait partie des gros
Scor moi moi j'avais pris le parti de
faire beaucoup de publicité parce que je
voulais vraiment l'UDI et et c'est vrai
que Y a Tristan WX génie le génie du PAF
Tristan Wex qui connait la télévision
comme moi je connais la charcuterie qui
avait dit c'est pas grâce à cyil Hanouna
qu'on a fait 3 millions bien entendu
c'est grâce à sa mère les chéis je
voudrais d'abord qu'on voit la bande
annonce à chaque fois tu as l'impression
dans complément d'enquête qu'il va se
passer un truc de fou et que Jordan
Bardella va faire la c'estavant
d'annonce attends VO il sont dir un truc
sur Michel fournir non mais c'est ça
exactement on dirait que tu on dirait
que vous allez faire faites entrer
l'accusé ou crime regardez qui va se
passer un truc de fou que la personne va
finir en prison à la fin du reportage
c'est regarde et finalement bah tu vois
qu'elle a acheté trois tragibus à la
cantine voilà regardez non mais c'est
c'est c'est des fous bonjour il a tout
d'un Le Pen mais ce n'est pas un Le Pen
complément d'enquête sur Jordan
vardellaa l'enfant prodige du RN qui se
rêve grand remplaçant de Marine Le Pen
voir d'Emmanuel Macron je pense que c un
animal politique le favori des sondages
aux européennes est-il en train de
réussir l'opération banalisation de
l'extrême droite derrière la com
révélation sur les petits et les grands
secrets de cet eurodéputé qui vit de la
politique depuis ses 19 ans alors ils
avaient fait exactement pareil bon c'est
devenu leur nouvelle technique la
bandeannonce AZ vu avec la musique qui
fait peur ou ex ilour début tu étais
d'accord et puis après tu veux plus y
aller finalement tu as changé d'avis ils
ont fait pareil au début tu es d'accord
pour participer au début franchement ils
sont venus nous voir il nous on fa un
complément d'enquête sur vous moi je
leur ai dit j'ai rien à cacher ouais on
vous prend avec nous c'est que je vous
donne des interviews on vous emmène avec
nous sur les déplacements vous interview
quiiv vous il y a pas de problème et
puis j'ai vu en fait que l'objectif de
ce travail était pas de faire un un un
portrait mais de faire un procès et il
fallait à chaque fois trouver le truc
qui n'allait pas à la rigur c'est le
boulot des journalistes mais ce qui m'a
posé problème et c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai arrêté de répondre c'est que on est
en période électorale il devait être
diffusé en juin il a été reporté en
septembre il dev diffusé en septembre il
Deva être diffusé en décembre il a été
repoussé au mois de janvier là on est
dans les 6 mois de campagne officielle
avant les élections européennes du 9
juin je suis probablement le seul
candidat qui aura droit à un complément
d'enquête sur le service public or moi
je pense que la vocation du service
public c'est pas de de démolir et et et
je dis que c'est un procès et pas un
portrait parce que l'objectif de ce de
ce documentaire c'est pas de faire un
travail journalistique c'est de détruire
c'est de démolir tuux vous dire c'est de
salir et c'est de faire du mal je vais
vous dire euh
vous savez comment ça se passe hein moi
j'ai eu plein de gens dès qu'il y a des
gens qui disent du bien de
vous il ne passe pas exactement par
contre quand il quand quand il y a des
gens qui disent du bien de vous ils sont
obligés de se justifier quand a des gens
qui disent du mal de vous là aucune
justification ils peuvent y aller il y a
aucune preuve qui sont demandé quand ils
disent quand quelqu'un il vous a pas
vous dites bah non franchement il était
super il m'a même prêté un jour 100000 €
il vous ouais bah donnez-moi les
justificatifs par contre quand il y a un
mec qui dit bah il m'a traité de connard
à la cafette ah bah très bien on le note
tout de suite merci non mais c'est des
génies excusez-moi c'est c'est quand
même c'est c'est des méthodes
excusez-moi mais de toutes les façons
même si les scores sont bons la marque
est extrêmement salie voilà et on le
sait on va revenir d'abord sur un
extrait ils ont d'abord retrouvé des
images de vous plus jeunes et vous aviez
déjà très envie d'aller loin en
politique regardez en janvier 2014 un
jeune homme meurt poignardé dans les
jardins du
Trocadero le père de la victime s'oppose
publiquement à un rassemblement organisé
par le FN peu importe pour le jeune
Bardella qui récupère le fait d'hiver
contre la vie de la famille il réite les
éléments de langage du
parti grand P la sécurité et sur le le
site du Front national mais vraiment le
l'idée de Marine Le Pen c'est d'arrêter
cette utopie du laxisme et de se placer
véritablement du côté des victimes et de
ne plus rien tolérer c'est véritablement
sur des interviews comme ça qu'on passe
d'un simple militant à pourquoi pas un
jeune
Poulin attendez bon hormis j'aime pas me
revoir quand j'ai 18 ans mais un pe pas
énormément changé plus question de point
de vue mais mais on dit donc il est il y
a eu un fait divers je crois qu'il y
avait une agression ave qu' un jeune de
mon âge à l'époque avait été poignardé
et il y a une manifestation qui est
organisée et en fait la manifestation
qui est organisée il y a un journaliste
qui me pose une question disant vous
accepterez de répondre donc moi c'est
première fois que je répond à une
question et ça se transforme en Parella
est venu il a récupéré le fait diviver
et cetera c'est c'est des en fait il y a
rien donc ils sont obligés d'écrire une
histoire et là probablement ils se
disent est né dans sa tête une envie de
devenir quelqu'un et cetera enfin ils
sont dans dans dans une bulle quoi
Jacques carardos qui était ancien
présentateur ouis surtout j'étais dans
la société de production il y a 6 mois
qui a été mandaté pour fabriquer ce
reportage et j'étais au côté de Pierre
Stéphan fort lorsqu'il a démarré le
tournage donc je sais exactement ce qui
s'est dit à ce moment-là et dans les et
après vos premiers jours de tournage
très vite pierre Stéphan a dit il est
trop lisse on y arrivera pas il y a rien
à aller chercher donc ils étaient déjà
très déçus du contenu mais surtout on a
eu une discussion assez vite avec les
responsables de complément d'enquête en
l'occurrence Hugo Plagnard qui a dit tu
comprends ce sujet on peut pas le rater
c'est le plus important pour nous et ça
m'a extrêmement choqué parce que je lu
dit pourquoi ben parce que il est prévu
peu de temps avant les Européennes et
donc il y avait un objectif de cibler de
vous cibler et de cibler ce de cibler le
timing c'est-à-dire à 5 6 mois des
européennes moi ça me choque beaucoup il
a g Verdes qui tr regarde mal je peux
dire
là très tranquille parce que si tu veux
j'étais au côté du rédacteur j'ai j'ai
participer au premier brainstorming sur
je peux aller plus
loin tout rouge on dirait qu'il est
derrière pas connais le dessous des
cartes de Châtillon je connais le
dessous des cartes de tous les tournages
donc je suis très tranquille je suis
très tranquille je dis pas qu'il fallait
pas faire d'enquête sur Jordan B c'est
une boîte de prod qu' a fait moi moi
c'était France Télévision en interne
parce qu'il y a aucune boîte de prod qui
avit voulu le FA
ou ou pas estce que vous leur avez fait
au boîte de prod non non je sais pas
personne n'a voulu le faire nous c'est
vrai c'est donc ils ont demandé en
interne à fonction de toute façon les
sujets qui sont les plus difficiles à
faire en règle générale on les demande à
l'extérieur parce que à l'extérieur la
boîte de prod elle a pas le choix ça lui
fait de l'argent donc elle dit pas non
puis en fait quand vous regardez le
contenu du
reportage moi j'ai le sentiment vraiment
du d'une malhonnêteté intellectuelle et
d'une escroque r c'està-dire que donc
ils ont rien trouvé ils trouvent
quelqu'un qui a travaillé avec nous il y
a plusieurs années qui dit bardellaa
avait un compte Twitter anonyme on on va
revenir là-dessus vous inqui le
lendemain la personne se rétracte elle
dit sur son compte Twitter ça n'était
pas bardé là derrière le compte Twitter
ce démenti n'est pas diffusé à l'antenne
il y a une autre personne qui a
travaillé avec moi lors de la dernière
élection européenne en en 2019 oui il va
porter plainte contre complément
d'enquête parce qu'il dit ce que j'ai
dit a été manipulé et en fait tout est
comme ça et tout le reste c'est de la
diffamation par insinuation alors on va
revenir sur cette cette AFF j'ai plein
d'exemples le faux compte Twitter on va
revenir un par un vous inquiétez pas on
a le temps euh faux compte Twitter
regardez les équipes de complement
d'enquête vous accuse d'être derrière ce
compte qui a été actif de 2015 à 2017
sur lequel on trouve des attaques envers
des journalistes ou encore des blagues
racistes pour affirmer ça il s'appuie
sur plusieurs témoignages anonymes
sachez qu'on les a contacté aujourd'hui
ils nous disent eux que ils sont sûr
d'eux h mais c'est qui les témoignages
anonyme ben parce que la seule personne
non mais c'est très intéressant nous on
sait qui est le propriétaire du compte
et je l'ai dit c'est c'est un ancien élu
du rassemblé national et je l'ai dit
dans l'entourage notamment de l'ancien
vice-président du RN et je l'ai dit aux
journalistes de compl et probablement
que la personne qui a insinué que
c'était moi qui à la lumière de la
menace d'une dépôt d'une plainte retire
son affirmation c'est que c'est
peut-être pas tout rose donc moi j'ai
dit au journalistes attention cette
histoire elle est plus compliquée que
cela on sait qui était le prop du compte
je l'ai dit aux journalistes les G n'ont
rien voulu entendre et au final la seule
source qui vient dire ce compte a
appartient et est géré par Jordan
Bardella se rétracte 2hures après en
disant finalement je ne sais pas qui est
derrière ce compte donc moi j'ai dit
soyez extrêmement prudent et on voit
bien qu'on tourne en rond parce qu'il
n'y a strictement rien à me reprocher je
n'ai qu'un seul compte Twitter et je
pense être quand même connu pour assumer
l'intégralité de mes propos et ceux
depuis que je fais de la politique on va
regarder ça
regarder celui qui se cache derrière
repnat du ghetto insulte les
journalistes qui lui déplaisent les
traitant de journalope un terme courant
à l'extrême droite
la figure de Jean-Marie Le Pen est
omniprésente
starifié côté humour repn du ghetto
semble trouver très drôle cette photo
qu'il partage on y voit une piscine de
banlieu parisienne assorti d'un
commentaire raciste la mer Noire mort de
rire il ironise sur le cas du jeune Théo
doln sbois gravement blessé à l'anus par
la matraque d'un
policier g est-ce que vous entendez les
sac vous vous dites quoi bon moi les
témoignages anonymes en journalisme
c'est une pratique qui peut se se plider
quand on n pas de gens qui fassent
caméra veulent plider après donc quand
on a quand on a rien on on fait
n'importe quoi vous c'est c'est c'est
c'est non moi je sais que dans le sport
j'utilisais ça parce que les gens ne
veulent pas parler à visage découvert
bon voilà B ça pour moi ça pour moi déjà
c'est c'est c'est ça déjà pour moi non
mais ça pour moi déjà c'est à la
poubelle voilà déjà directement c'est à
la poubelle c'est à la poubellereun de
la voà MO auss je peux dire n'importe
quoi moi demain je peux être anonyme
bien sû sachant que vous savez
excusez-moi mais il y a des journalistes
autour de ce plateau vous savez bien que
parfois les sources anonymes n'existent
pas ex pratique non mais vous discutez
oui tu donc tu vas faire croire à des
millions de téléspectateurs un mec à 50
% c'est vrai ou c'est faux donc bravo
vas-y non mais vas-y c'est ton truc
vas-y non c'est
pas là ils disent qu'il y en a tro ou
vas-y après je vois pas pourquoi ils
auraient inventer cyil dit aujourd'hui
il maintiennent pourquoi Monsieur
Bardella il risque une plainte vous les
avez prévenu avant n'enlève pas la
séquence c'est qu'ils sont sur deux moi
oui mais moi je vous le redemande est-ce
que vous avez utilisé ce compte
cautionné ce compte non monsieur verd
mais je vous mets à l'aise non et j'ai
répondu les journalistes m'ont posé leur
question je leur ai dit non ce que je
trouve vous dites ils ont une source
mais la source elle-même c'est rétracté
celle qui apparaît à l'antenne
exactement elle a dit
finalement un ce compte appartient à G
de le lendemain le lendemain elle a dit
je crois que ce compte n'appartient pas
je suis trompé et je ne sais pas à qui
il appartient donc franchement un an ils
n'ont rien trouvé et honnêtement ce
complément d'enquête il tourne autour
d'un compte Twitter c'est ça le truc qui
était censé me me faire tomber on va
faire tomber le rassemblement nacial on
est en train de discuter là d'un compte
Twitter avec marqué marquy am chicha et
Jean-Marie Le Pen en Superman en
bannière non mais mernoire c'est pas
très heureux quand même très heureux